[Music]
hey guys Amanda Leeds here we're back in
Doncaster and I'm going to be showing
you the final results of the house that
I've been working on let's have a look
so here we are in the living room it was
the living room before so it's just been
freshly redecorated and then the new
addition to this room is the smoke alarm
which is linked to the smoke alarm
system for the house because it's going
to be a chiller so now looking out into
the garden we've got a separate garden
area to the new space that's been
created just for car parking
we could probably fear three cars
comfortably on that drive so I think
that'll be a good selling point for this
house because there isn't any on-road
parking at the front so this property
when I bought it was just a normal
three-bedroom house I've now turned it
into a four bedroom HMO and it's just in
time before Doncaster becomes an article
for area so now we just need to make
sure that we get those tenants in so
that we have that right to have it as a
four-bedroom HMO forever even after
article four comes in
[Music]
so the house was purchased for 94
thousand pounds it costs eleven thousand
pounds to do it as a four-bedroom hatre
and that cost includes an interlinking
smoke alarm system the fire doors and
also a full rewire as well as some damp
proofing works because there was some
damp coming into the utility in the
kitchen so that needs it to be rectified
so we've had a bit of a delay on the
program which is something that does
happen and it's had a bit of a knock-on
effect because because the paintin
hasn't been done the carpets could have
been laid and now the paint has to dry
before the carpets accumulate so that's
caused a bit of a delay and so as we're
here now the builders are finishing up
fair bits with the decorators and then
the carpet Fischer is going to come in
later this week and lay the carpets and
then it will be good to go upstairs now
in bedroom two and as you can see a lots
changed from the last time that I was
here it's all been redecorated and the
only thing now that needs to be tweaked
as the carpet because if you remember
the walls have moved to this war was
knocked down and moved in to create more
space in the bedroom next door so the
carpets now have to be recut to fit this
room and then in the other rooms that
we're going to be having new carpets on
in those rooms and also on the stairs
and landing
so here's the bedroom if they've all had
a bit of a knock-on effect so there was
one room that was less than six and a
half square meters which was the minimum
requirement so in order to bring that up
to the standard that's required by the
council you had to move this wall to
create more space in that bedroom and as
a result it made this room a little bit
smaller so to create more space in this
room we're not into the other room which
was the biggest room so all of the rooms
now are a good size we've got three
double bedrooms and we've got one single
bedroom this is the single bedroom and
this war was about here initially and it
was knocked down and it's been pushed
back I don't know maybe like a foot it's
now a reasonably sized room big enough
to fit a single bed a wardrobe and a
chest of drawers and on all the bedrooms
we've got the fire doors and but we've
also got instead of keys this digit key
lock so each of the tenants will have a
code that they put in to enter their
room sometimes tenants lose keys and the
can't get into their room so this is a
really good one because this is always
going to be there and they can always
get into their bedroom even if you don't
have keys
[Music]
so in the bathroom the things really
changed and that was the time all along
the bathroom was in quite good condition
so it just probably needs a really good
deep clean but it's actually really good
to go so nothing's changed in here so
just on the landing and upstairs in the
house we've got a light and we've also
got an emergency light in case there was
a powder but the light is on a timer
which is quite good because sometimes
tenants forget to switch lights off so
this just means that no one has to
remember to turn the light off if
someone walks into the hallway and it's
dark it will automatically come on which
is also quite safe because it means that
no one would ever have a trip down the
stairs in the dark so yeah basically
what we've done is we're just career
drop the fence from here I'm stab at the
edges to low I'll get at parking spaces
obviously a lot area to mow down dear
dark I've allocated space there'll be a
good selling point
yep for the tenants going forward
they've still got a private garden so no
one can just see them if they set out
set out in the garden but then they've
also obviously got the car parking space
which is I think is really good yeah
where we're going to achievement this
car parking space
remember the trees at the back of course
yeah thank you so much so you guys are
now clearing up and then the carpet is
gonna come later this week copy that's
it thank you so much it's been great
doing business with you
[Music]
Nathan's taking this property on for me
as a lease option agreement and you're
gonna have it for seven years isn't it
seven years and in seven years time he's
going to purchase the property for one
hundred and forty thousand and in the
meantime you're gonna be paying us a
guaranteed rent or five fifty a month
and whilst you're letting it out at the
hey Chandler and just basically being in
charge and responsible for the property
most of all take on all the
responsibilities so you guys it is a
passive investor yeah
phone calls yeah when you buy it yeah
it's a win-win as an Edwin it's it's a
really good deal because yeah I'm glad
that yeah I won't have to yeah and you
live close to it as well so it's quite
convenient I mean we're at far certainly
yeah so it's it's really good good news
all around really I'm really pleased
with how it's turned out initially I
wanted to do it as two separate flats
that's what I was thinking but it wasn't
going to work out that way and it wasn't
going to stack up financially I think
this way is really good because we're
going to have the rights to have it at
the HMO forever so I know I'm under and
Samuel personally so obviously I'm a
property investor like they are we got
chatting about this property probably a
few months ago now and it was one that
they kind of wanted to you know hand
pass on really because they're obviously
quite busy people so we agreed for me to
take it on a purchase lease option where
I'll lease the property from them all
the time and have the option to buy at a
set price sort of within a set period so
I think that's over six or seven years
and I I'll pay about five or fifty
pounds per month to them to leave the
property I'll have a purchase price one
hundred and forty thousand in seven
years time I'll then rent it out as an
HMO in the meantime so I'll probably
make about six or seven hundred pounds
per month profit from this property the
deal is I take on all the hassle and
because I you know because I make the
majority of the profit and for those
guys it'll be a pansy
of passive investment so it works for
all parties to win win this sir
properties only just finished so we're
already in October now for those savvy
investors of you that know Doncaster
article four comes in this month so I
think we're about a week or two weeks
away from the article for hitting so you
know the deadlines pretty tight for me
to kind of get this rented out because
once I get it rented out of HML I'll
have what's known as the grandfather
rights for me to then use this property
as a HTML despite the fact that article
falls in so my job now is to get this
rented out as quickly as possible so
I'll need to furnish it and I'll need to
advertise and get people in and so my
strategy is because properties increase
in value quite a lot when they've got
grandfather why's it's worth Mike it's
worth my investment to say we'll do
these rooms for a rent free period get
it filled off get the tenancy and get a
st signed and then that achieves the
objective really so we can get that done
pretty quickly so working with a man has
been fantastic she's obviously a lovely
lovely lady she's very easy to work with
very easy to get on with and yeah we've
as a result this process where we're now
good friends and as I say it's a win-win
so maybe we'll do project in the future
who knows so that's the end of this
project here in Doncaster guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you've
enjoyed watching the process and the
transformation of this house as much as
I have
if you'd like to watch more of these
type of videos then click here and don't
forget to subscribe thanks for watching
bye
[Music]